Я знаю що це політична історія Я знаю що
у владі вигідно депутата Київради
погребицького який є по
сутіонером якомога довше тримати за
гачок отакими судовому засіданнями ну
справу Вже можна було давно закрити за
відсутністю доказів
виправдати і
негабитись просто це ж не я Гануся вони
скажіть випиті
справи
Як підозрюваний в нападі на державного
діяча в минулому народного депутата від
упсж е-е Волошина Які на даний момент
має підозру про державну зраду
переховуються від органів служби безпеки
України який втік
з країн за тиждень чи за два я не
пам'ятаю
тобто до початку
широкомасштабної війни в той час коли я
взяв в руки зброю
в той час коли я формував батальйон
територіальної оборони
евакує піднявся
рсу звільняв Херсон Бахмут був в
оточенні в солідарі отримав дві бойові
травми Ну і продовжую службу і те саме
штурмових військах на даний момент
навчаю передаю свій досвід бойовий
мобілізованим громадянам які пройшли Але
ж ви не нападали на нього Можете так
коротко нагадати просто історію цього
року я якраз Коли відбувався цей студент
Я проходив повз був поряд ну це
буквально переді мною відбулася багато
людей бачили Це відеозаписи і мене
спочатку ніхто і не затримав
але в потім підійшла поліція чому ж
затримала мене і
так само я став підозрюваним на цій
справі Ну окей Я знаю що правда за мною
час вже розставляє всі крапки Нади
єдине що замість того щоб наприклад я
зараз перший день відбудуться
хотілося б а по-перше підтягнути свої
депутати справи допомогти людям в Києві
БД друге трошки перепочити переключитись
побачити рідних друзів знайомих я от
бачите тут знаходжусь з самого ранку
Скажіть скільки часу вже в суді
розглядається ця справа чому постійно
переноситься і яка нині ситуація чому не
сталося
вже пішов третій рік
на даний момент ще відбулось попереднє
засідання
воно постійно переноситься по різним
причинам
то з причинності більшість переносів
спричин сунду самого там щось не
відбувалося потім була причина
у зв'язку з уточненням даних по службі
бо по справі не тільки я проходжу ще
один військовослужбовець
Ну і ось сьогодні мало Вже якби
по суті
він точно був там всі необхідні
документи по другому військовослужбовців
вже було зібрані які підтверджують те що
він проходить
але ну очікувано для мене суддя подала у
відставку сьогодні тому знову засідання
сьогодні не відбулося воно буде
перенесено я
так розказали
канцелярії що буде призначений новий
суддя він вже буде розглядати цю справу
про що мене буде повідомлено окремо
поїзд